Hello, scholars.
Look at your grades.
Now look at mine.
Now back at your grades, now back to mine.
Sadly, they're not like mine.
But if you stopped studying in a cave and started studying like me, they could be like mine.
Look at your shirt.
Now back at mine.
Look down, back up.
Where are you?
You're in the library, with the man your grades could be like!
Did you know that eight out of five dentists say that studying in the library...
...is six bajillion times more effective than studying in your shower?
Close your eyes.
Now open your eyes.
Where are you?
You're in a beautifully quiet place where you can study.
Look at your hand.
Now back to me.
I have it.
It's a laptop with access to bucketloads of library databases.
Look again.
The laptop is now a celestial sandwich here in the snack zone.
Anything is possible when you're in the library.
I'm on a cart.